monsieur le Premier vice-président du
Sénat
monsieur le Premier testeur du Sénat que
je vois ici au fond sagement dans cette
salle
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la présidente de la délégation
droit des femmes chers collègues
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
est chargés de faire Madame et Monsieur
les professeurs Monsieur le Secrétaire
général
chers amis du grand continent
merci de votre mobilisation pour faire
de ces rencontres un succès et vous tous
mesdames et messieurs j'aurai salué ici
les nombreux étudiants qui sont ici
présents et qui je n'en doute pas feront
leur miel de nos échanges et pourront y
participer tout à l'heure
il est des habitudes qui méritent d'être
cultivé
et je suis heureux d'être parmi vous
pour ouvrir cette deuxième rencontre au
Sénat du grand continent
après la place de la France et de
l'Europe face au rivalité entre la Chine
et les États-Unis et avouer que
l'actualité nous rappelle que ça n'était
pas un thème j'allais dire hors sol or
géopolitique et hors temps
c'est la démocratie en Europe et en
France que nous nous apprêtons à
ausculter dans un contexte de crise qui
interroge le rôle de chaque acheteur
institutionnel et naturellement les
parlements
je tiens à rappeler le sens de nos
rencontres qui est de multiplier les
passerelles entre le monde académique et
l'univers parlementaire
dans le chaos des certitudes tranchantes
de l'immédiatet triomphante nous avons
fait ensemble avec vous qu'en continuant
le choix d'un autre tempo la réflexion
la mise à distance le rejet de
l'impulsivité
qui tient lieu trop souvent de force de
conviction
télé
le 30 sénateur évoqué dans la fable de
La Fontaine
dans le lièvre et la tortue donc je
rappelle toujours qu'elle a été écrit un
moment le Sénat n'existait point
et où c'était le souvenir du Sénat
romain qui incarnait la sagesse et la
paix c'est donc loin ce train de
sénateur d'être synonyme d'hésitation
il veut octroyer la décision des racines
solides prendre le temps c'est écouter
et entendre en épousant le pas de la
sagesse
mesdames et messieurs
la démocratie
européenne est confrontée à une crise
aux multiples facettes crise économique
et sociale inflation
crise de l'identité
monter des radicalité tendance il
libérale
guerre aux portes j'allais dire en
Europe
la crise ne se limite d'ailleurs pas aux
frontières de l'Union européenne comme
on a témoigné aux yeux du monde l'assaut
du Capitole c'était le 6 janvier 2021 à
Washington
cette crise ne me paraît pas cependant
contester les fondements du modèle
démocratique
il est pas de société européenne qui
envisage de rompre avec l'héritage
démocratique au profit de régime
autoritaires personne personne dans nos
pays ne peut considérer sérieusement que
les régimes autoritaires soient mieux
armés pour affronter les grands défis
malgré des tentations qui ont existé
mais vite dissipées au premier temps de
l'épidémie de covid
à contrario existe dans nos sociétés une
vive dénonciation d'un déficit de
démocratie et un appétit de plus en plus
grand pour la démocratie participative
on peut d'ailleurs se demander si la
crise n'est pas consubstantielle à la
démocratie la démocratie porte en elle
un état de tension entre majorité et
minorité
la promesse d'expression de la volonté
de chacun et en fait
aussitôt par sa dissolution dans
le destin collectif
la démocratie en plus me paraît sans
cesse perfectible
avec la question les démocraties
européennes sont-elles menacées dans
leur existence face à la crise présente
point d'interrogation je réponds ce
n'est pas ma conviction
parlons de la démocratie en France et de
la crise dans notre pays
les comparaisons européennes sont
souvent instrumentalisées pour lisser
les effets de la crise dans tel ou tel
pays
et montrer que la situation est
finalement moins grave ou en tout
comparable je pense aussi une erreur de
perspective
la France perte sert tous les traits des
crises européennes mais ils ne sont plus
accusés en son sein que dans les pays de
son voisinage
pays de voisinage qui ont su canaliser
les expressions politiques les plus
radicales regardez récemment en Espagne
ou conforter une culture du pacte social
premier compromis le compromis des
polders dont on parle peu aux Pays-Bas
mais qui parle à un ancien ministre du
Travail qui en charge la réforme de
l'article premier du Code du travail
mais aussi
secrétaire général honoraire en
Allemagne
qui connaissez bien la situation
politique en Allemagne où trouver une
formule
identitaire
faisons le lien entre des traditions et
une modernité
et modernité dans les sens et d'être
ouverte sur le monde
faut-il réfléchir l'exemple du
Royaume-Uni sur ce sujet
la France est un précipité singulier un
alliage inédit entre interrogation
identité et commotion sociale
la crise française actuelle n'est pas
non plus la simple résultante de choix
non réglés ou de décision trop longtemps
reportée
toute crise puise indéniablement ses
racines dans le passé mais elle ne se
produit qu'à un moment donné et pas un
autre
fermez les yeux sur ce moment
l'écarter d'un revers de main pour
renvoyer les responsabilités à ces
prédécesseurs reviendrait une forme
d'aveuglement c'est l'expression de
pierre aux envallons et d'échecs dans
l'exercice du pouvoir
il serait vain enfin de tenter d'édifier
les barrières étanches entre crise
sociale et crise politique toute
contestation sociale ne débouche pas
nécessairement sur le champ politique
mais rare sont les contestations
politiques qui ne soient pas nourries de
contestation sociale la contestation
sociale n'est pas le degré mineur de la
contestation politique auquel on
voudrait la circonscrire elle en devient
l'une des expressions c'est le
glissement entre les deux phénomènes qui
permet au mieux de saisir la portée de
la crise française
bien au-delà de la question
naturellement cruciale
des retraites alors
crise politique
crise des institutions
crise démocratique crise de régime je
suis avec des points d'interrogation je
sais que parmi nos intervenants de ce
soir il existe des analyses différentes
de la mienne mais je crois que c'est
l'intérêt de ce type de débat
crise de gouvernance sans aucun doute
pour moi et crise de l'autorité crise
d'une autorité qui se voulait
jupitérienne et verticale et à chercher
à contourner depuis des années le
Parlement
les territoires les corps intermédiaires
crises de la capacité à convaincre par
une parole de vérité et non des effets
d'annonce ou d'éléments de langage
répété jusqu'à qu'ils attiennent la
vacuité crise de résultats certainement
parce que trop souvent les mesures
annoncées l'ont été encore et encore
avec des effets réduits
crise entre la France oubliée et la
France de toutes les opportunités donc
crise de cohésion nationale lorsque des
paroles brutales divisent lorsque
l'intégration est abandonnée aux
communautarisme
crise dans l'exercice du pouvoir
assurément
la responsabilité politique n'est-elle
pas de rechercher le moyen de conjuguer
la légalité et la légitimité d'éviter
quand ils donnent de défis créons
et d'accorder et là je convoque
Montesquieu la lettre et l'esprit des
lois
force est de reconnaître que ce ressort
démocratique c'est grippé
mais avant tout c'est la crise d'un
pouvoir du pouvoir en place qui doit
trouver une issue politique au-delà d'un
chapelet de mesure technique dont on
peine à distinguer le fil conducteur
quelle perspective de sortie de crise
a-t-elle été définie oui qu'elle
perspective a été définie cette question
majeure demeure encore aujourd'hui sans
réponse
je ne fais pas partie vous l'avez
compris de ceux qui invoquent une crise
systémique je crois en la responsabilité
politique
mesdames et messieurs
le Parlement par le contrôle de l'action
gouvernementale par le vote de la loi
permet d'ajuster la lettre à l'esprit la
légalité à la légitimité démocratique il
est au cœur du contrat social au cours
de ces dernières semaines je le dis dans
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales le Sénat fait la
démonstration qu'il était en mesure
d'accueillir un débat riche parfois vif
parfois même très vif de basculant
jamais dans la victime en cohérence avec
ses convictions est capable de se
prononcer sur le fond dans une totale
indépendance du pouvoir en place des
injonctions politiques ou des émotions
du moment
me paraît avoir dans sa diversité
assumée sa mission qui est aussi une
mission d'être un balancier
stabilisateur des instituts
je crois que le bicaméric est une chance
parce qu'il n'aligne pas de façon
systématique les majorités législatives
parce que le Sénat est ma nation des
collectivités territoriales est autant
attachée aux libertés locales aux
libertés individuelles et collective il
est l'un des carents en période de crise
il se méfie toujours des lois de pulsion
quand on annonce le mercredi un projet
de loi pour des événements s'étant situé
le dimanche nous venons de le vivre
aujourd'hui même c'est la réalité
politique de l'instant
oui
lorsque les temps sont troublés la
tentation en France
est forte lancer un chantier
institutionnel
qui est souvent un écran dissimulant une
forme de faiblesse politique
ne touchons à la constitution que d'une
main tremblante prenons garde aux
ajustements qualifiés techniques qui
bouleversent en fait des équilibres
institutionnels subtiles
je n'ignore pas que ce séjour vrai
besoin de respiration démocratique et je
le mets au pluriel elles ne peuvent être
de pure forme le référendum est l'un des
instruments de cette respiration mais
faisons attention à ce que la décision
du peuple soit respectée ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas je pense
référendum en France sur la Constitution
européenne de 2005
et localement au référendum sur Notre
Dame des Landes deux exemples qui
conduisent parfois douter et ne croyez
pas nous nous faisons encore reprocher
puisque j'ai appartenu j'allais dire ce
gouvernement les conséquences que nous
n'avons pas tirées du référendum de 2005
du surnom bouleversé un peu la donne en
Europe c'est quand même une réalité dont
je peux faire état
la seconde instrument de cette
respiration démocratique peut-être le
découplage des élections présidentielles
législatives pour retisser le lien
distendu avec les citoyens redonner
confiance et enrayer une abstention
toujours plus élevée tout cela mérite
d'être examiné d'ailleurs le président
de la commission des lois et là et nous
sommes en train de l'examiner dans le
cadre du groupe de travail
institutionnel
je terminerai par un mot sur la relation
des parlements nationaux avec le Conseil
la Commission et le Parlement européen
européen est en pluriel parce que ce
sont ces trois
institutions que je souhaite interroger
les citoyens européens aspirent plus de
démocratie et légitimité dans une
décision européenne qui paraît encore à
beaucoup éloigné de leur préoccupation
et parfois technocratique l'Union
européenne qui protège est aussi celle
qui impose certaines normes dont ils
contestent le bien-fondé or la
compétence des parlements nationaux
malgré le traité de Lisbonne reste
difficile à mettre en oeuvre contrainte
par des règles de procédure corsetés
restreinte dans ses capacités d'orienter
des choix majeurs quelques exemples
dans l'approbation des traités de
libre-échange
quel rôle reste-t-il au Parlement
nationaux
on l'a vu avec le CETA
encore le pouvoir
dossier du MERCOSUR ou de l'accord avec
la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est typiquement à
des saisissements des parlements
nationaux comment effectuer un contrôle
de subsidiarité efficace lorsque la
Commission européenne en maîtrise les
règles l'appréciation sur le fond et le
calendrier quand on reparle de la
doctrine de la séparation là on se pose
des questions la crise de la démocratie
européenne revêt aussi le visage d'un
défaut d'association des parlements
nationaux je le dis devant le président
de la commission pour l'Union européenne
avec ses côtés j'aurais vraiment saluer
Jean-Baptiste non parce que si on est là
on lui doit beaucoup cher Jean-Baptiste
blanc et je voulais vraiment vous
remercier il est en train de faire un
travail absolument passionnant mais
assez rébarbatif sur un objet très
particulier qui s'appelle le 0
artificialisation net dont il est devenu
ici le chantre et le connaisseur oui
je reviens au défaut de l'Association
des parlements nationaux il s'agit d'un
chantier immense que la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'Europe n'a effleuré
en dehors de ces parlementaires
vraiment je voulais
remarquer au retour de la conférence de
Prague où vous représentiez le Sénat
que la voix de la France au moment de la
présidente française ne s'est guère fait
entendre pour promouvoir le rôle des
parlements nationaux
mesdames et messieurs j'aurais pu dans
le fond me contenter de citer de
Churchill dans son discours la Chambre
des communes le 11 novembre 1947
celui qui comporte son célèbre à
forrisme la démocratie et la pire forme
de gouvernement à l'exception de tous
les autres mais je suis revenu à lire ce
discours
en fait il est dans l'opposition il est
dans l'opposition à Clément atelier
et qu'est-ce qu'il dit quand le
gouvernement veut amenuiser le pouvoir
de veto de la chambre haute il déclare
il déclare
la démocratie ne signifie pas nous avons
une majorité je le cite peu importe
comment et nous avons un bail pour 5 ans
nous avons une majorité peu importe
fin de citation à méditer
et Churchill de poursuivre
Churchill de poursuivre le gouvernement
du peuple par le peuple pour le peuple
voilà la définition souveraine de la
démocratie est-ce que tout n'est pas dit
et je voudrais remercier Jean-François
Papin parce que
si aujourd'hui nous abordons ce thème
c'est à lui que nous le devons comme
président de la commission pour l'Union
européenne et je voulais vous dire que
puisqu'on va parler d'Europe qu'ici la
question européenne n'est pas une
question subsidiaire elle est une
question transversale pour chacune de
nos commissions et l'organisation que
nous avons dans une commission pour
l'Union européenne et quelque chose de
particulièrement intéressant avec
notamment des dispositifs d'alerte sur
les surtranspositions que nous avons mis
en place ici que tous les parlements
nationaux n'ont pas encore mis en place
mais qui nous apparaissent extrêmement
important je vous souhaite une
excellente moment de partage et
d'échanges et je donne immédiatement la
parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président cher Gérard
Larcher Mesdames et Messieurs mes
collègues de
président de commission monsieur le
Premier testeur madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
Madame et Monsieur le Professeur émérite
Monsieur le Secrétaire général honoraire
mes chers collègues sénateurs mes chers
collègues
je suis particulièrement heureux ce soir
dans le sillage du président Larcher
d'ouvrir la deuxième édition des
Rencontres du grand continent au Sénat
je saisis cette occasion pour souligner
combien le partenariat scellé entre
notre assemblée et votre revue me semble
opportun en qualité de président de la
commission des affaires européennes
j'estime en effet que l'ambition du
Sénat d'être le creuset d'un débat
public représentatif prospectif et
stratégique prend toute sa valeur quand
elle se place d'une part à la bonne
échelle c'est-à-dire celle de notre
continent et d'autre part à la bonne
distance avec L'écume des jours
dirais-je c'est à dire quand elle
parvient à transcender
la caducité du tweet
c'est ce même positionnement qui je le
comprends distingue votre revue qui a su
en seulement 4 ans s'imposer comme une
référence de premier plan
en misant d'emblée sur la traduction en
plusieurs langues européennes le grand
continent atteste sa conscience aiguë
que tous les peuples européens doivent
naturellement prendre part au débat
public sur les enjeux du monde
contemporain contemporain en prenant du
champ avec l'actualité tout en suivant
de près votre revue elle s'autorise à
voir plus loin et plus haut ou plus au
fond ce qui revient au même et en temps
structuré une réflexion informée grâce
au croisement de divers disciplines
c'est ainsi qu'elle peut légitimement
ambitionner de nourrir utilement le
débat public et donc naturellement celui
qui nous anime ici au sein
c'est à ce même effort de prise de
distance que nous sommes invités ce soir
pour appréhender ce qu'il advient de la
démocratie dans les crises que traverse
notre continent c'est-à-dire dans ces
moments rares qui appellent une réponse
urgente pouvant justifier des procédures
dérogatoires et le contournement
exceptionnel des parlements Ilion
européenne n'a pas été conçue pour
répondre à de tels crises dans la
gestion ressort plus naturellement des
états doté d'instruments d'urgence à
cette fin pourtant crise financière
crise économique crise migratoire crise
sanitaire crise climatique
l'Europe semble enchaîner les crises
depuis 15 ans et depuis la guerre en
Ukraine le rythme s'accélère crise des
réfugiés crises énergétiques crise
inflationniste voir bientôt crise
alimentaire l'Europe n'enchaîne plus les
crises elle les cumule et les citoyens
attendent toujours plus qu'à y répondre
si des entorses au fonctionnement normal
de la démocratie se justifie en temps de
crise et que la crise devient un état
permanent comment alors éviter le coup
d'état permanent au niveau européen si
je peux m'autoriser cette référence bref
comment préserver le bon fonctionnement
démocratique de l'Europe dans les
moments critiques
qu'observe-t-on à cet égard le contexte
de crise alimente plusieurs évolutions
préoccupantes dans le jeu institutionnel
européen d'abord la crise s'impose à
l'agenda des chefs d'État ou de
gouvernement réunis au sein du Conseil
européen
c'est même l'indice majeur de sa gravité
de fait le fameux triangle
institutionnel Commission européenne
Conseil de l'Union européenne Parlement
européen se transforment ainsi en carré
avec l'entrée en jeu du Conseil européen
or le contrôle démocratique sur ce club
des dirigeants nationaux étaient nus
certes il s'exerce à l'occasion des
élections générales dans chaque État
membre mais il s'agit d'un contrôle
ponctuel le contrôle parlementaire sur
le Conseil européen lui reste indirect
et pointilliste quand la Grèce menace de
quitter la zone euro quand l'économie
étouffe sous le confinement imposé par
la pandémie quand l'Ukraine agressé
frappe à la porte de l'Union européenne
c'est bien le Conseil européen qui
décide un plan de sauvetage à la Grèce
un emprunt mutualisé pour un plan de
relance ou l'ouverture de négociation
d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine autant de
décision qui avec la Libye de la crise
et au nom de l'urgence échappe au
Parlement alors qu'elles engagent
lourdement les peuples européens
deuxième évolution institutionnelle qui
met à mal la démocratie européenne en
tant que crise le recours croissant de
la Commission européenne aux outils
juridiques qui l’autorise à faire
l'économie du détour parlementaire
depuis quelques années nous pouvons en
effet observer qu'elle choisit le plus
souvent de proposer de nouvelles
législations européennes sous la forme
de règlement
plutôt
que d'autres directives par exemple le
règlement étant d'applications directes
il permet d'éviter la transposition de
la règle européenne en droit national et
donc au nom de l'efficacité il prive le
législateur national de toute latitude
de même la commission multiplie les
renvois des actes délégués dans ces
propositions législatives s'octroyant
ainsi la liberté de légiférer seul et
vite dans un champ de plus en plus
étendu
ce faisant elle tient les parlements
nationaux toujours plus à l'écart du
processus législatif européen alors même
que par exemple le pacte vert européen
engage de manière très structurante
notre agriculture nos transports ou nos
logements dans la transition écologique
le contexte de crise est venu légitimer
voire alimenter cette tendance de fond
le Parlement européen lui-même se
trouvant évincé je n'aborderai pas ici
la question sensible de la légitimité
respective voire concurrente des
parlements nationaux et du Parlement
européen je veux seulement évoquer la
part grandissante des textes législatifs
que la Commission propose sur le
fondement de la procédure accélérée qui
est prévue à l'article 122 du traité sur
le fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
cet article permet au conseil de décider
de mesures appropriées en cas d'urgence
plus exactement en cas de catastrophe
d'événements exceptionnels ou de rupture
d'approvisionnement en certains produits
c'est ainsi que le Conseil a pu
s'entendre en quelques semaines sur des
achats communs de vaccins ou de gaz sans
aucune intervention du Parlement
européen même a posteriori
est-ce le prix à payer pour répondre à
la crise avec la réactivité qu'elle
exige rappelons toutefois que la crise
exige tout autant
tout autant discernement que réactivité
l'étymologie est ici éclairante car le
verbe grec crinéine dont dérivent le mot
crise signifie discerner passer au
crible et de ce point de vue l'étape du
débat public est irremplaçable le
Parlement comme lieu naturel de ce débat
ne saurait donc être court-circuité
durablement ni la démocratie européenne
être sacrifiée sur l'hôtel de la crise à
sa mesure la commission des affaires
européennes du Sénat il va être
quotidiennement président de la
gentiment rappelé d'abord en exerçant un
contrôle attentif du respect par l'Union
européenne du principe de subsidiarité
afin que l'Union n'en Piette pas plus
que nécessaire sur les compétences
nationales ensuite en dénonçant la
dérive consistant à légiférer par voie
de règlement ou d'autres actes délégués
enfin en proposant des pistes comme elle
l'a fait l'an dernier après y avoir
travaillé avec ses homologues
européennes durant la présidence
française de l'Union pour renforcer le
rôle des parlements nationaux dans la
construction européenne car si nous
concitoyens conçoivent de plus en plus
l'Europe comme la seule réponse à la
hauteur des crises que nous traversons
il s'attendent légitimement à ce que
cette réponse européenne correspondent à
leurs vœux c'est-à-dire qu'elle résulte
d'un discernement opéré au terme d'un
débat démocratique ce temps du débat
c'est celui des parlements je remercie
donc par avance les philosophes
historiens sociologues et praticiens de
la politique européenne qui ont bien
voulu répondre à notre invitation de
nous éclairer ce soir sur cette délicate
articulation entre crise et démocratie
en Europe sur cette tension entre
l'urgence et le temps du débat qui ne
peut sans doute se résoudre que dans une
juste appréciation politique de la
temporalité je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai le président du Sénat monsieur le
Premier Vice-Président madame la
Présidente de la Commission les affaires
sociales monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
Président de la Commission les affaires
européennes mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs chers Jean-Baptiste blanc
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
chers lectrices chers lecteur mesdames
et messieurs
nous tenions à vous remercier toutes et
tous pour votre présence ce soir et à
vous dire en peu de mots combien nous
sommes heureux de cette deuxième édition
que cette deuxième édition des
Rencontres du grand continent au Sénat
soit encore une fois un succès
d'affluence et dans la lignée de ce qui
vient d'être dit par le président du
Sénat et par le président de la
commission des affaires européennes que
je remercie pour leurs mots très fort et
qui nous servent de viatique pour cette
pour cette discussion nous voulions tout
de même en quelques mots rappeler quelle
est l'ambition de ces rencontres pour
nous structurer évidemment dans la
continuité de ce que nous faisons en
ligne et au format papier aux éditions
Gallimard dans toutes les bonnes
librairies
dans le grand continent structuré un
débat public informé et ouvert face à
une époque de transformation profonde de
transformation urgente nous en parlerons
aussi ce soir dans une temporalité
éclatée dans laquelle il est parfois
bien difficile de trouver des lieux
adéquats pour prendre du recul et de la
hauteur et le Sénat à cet égard en est
très certainement un
et précisément c'est parce qu'il est au
coeur de l'appréhension du temps long
qu'il est à l'écoute aussi les tendances
de fond que le Sénat est un partenaire
auquel le grand continent est
particulièrement fier d'être associé
cette année dans le cadre de ce cycle de
trois événements ce dialogue nécessaire
entre le savoir et la décision qui est
au cœur de notre démarche et au cœur de
la démarche du groupe d'études
géopolitiques qui est le centre de
recherche qui édite le grand continent
doit identifier les lieux et les
occasions pour se déployer et celle-ci
en fait partie à cet égard ces
rencontres sont une occasion de faire
dialoguer des signatures de la revue
avec les sénateurs des commissions
concernées pour apporter un éclairage
nouveau libre et ouvert bénéficiant du
regard croisé entre parlementaires et
experts et nous y tenons beaucoup
le président de la commission des
Affaires européenne a rappelé très
gentiment le parcours du grand continent
finalement depuis 2019 où nous sommes
donné l'ambition d'être la revue de
référence du débat stratégique politique
et intellectuel à l'échelle pertinente
sommes aujourd'hui la première revue de
l'espace francophone par le nombre de
nos signatures et de nos lecteurs et nos
articles sont discutés et commentés
partout en Europe grâce à une stratégie
que vous avez rappelé de multilinguisme
là aussi à laquelle nous tenons beaucoup
depuis l'année dernière nous sommes
aussi en papier avec ce premier volume
donc politique de l'intérêt et sur le
web bien sûr et l'adresse le grand
continent.eu plus de 1000 signatures se
côtoient chaque jour dans nos colonnes
et nous organisons des débats comme ceci
presque chaque semaine de Paris à Rome
de Madrid à Varsovie et évidemment et
évidemment aussi dans des formats où
nous faisons dialoguer donc savoir
savoir et décision je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
c'est presque devenu une banalité de le
dire nos démocratie sont en crise de
Christie européenne sont en crise
presque partout des grands partis
implose ou ce fracture les cadres vols
en éclat les gonds de pacte situé à ne
tiennent plus d'un urgence des crises
c'est un terrain dans lequel nous sommes
embarqués entre le covid et la guerre à
l'Ukraine dans le tourbillon des
transformations anthropologiques de
notre époque de la transition écologique
à la transition numérique nous avons
peut-être perdu un route certains des
éléments qui sont au fondement de nos
démocraties
alors que l'exception fait la règle que
le cours normal des institutions semble
par moment dans un état critique ne
faudrait-il pas revenir en redécouvrir
comme nous l'invite le président du
Sénat et peut-être pour paraphraser
Chateaubriand à redécouvrir le génie du
parlementarisme
pour en parler ce soir nous aurons le
plaisir de faire dialoguer trois
signatures de la revue trois personnes
étaient de premier plan qui sont
illustrés par leur compréhension fine
des enjeux contemporains et des
transformations de nos démocraties en
Europe tant sur un plan théorique que
sur un plan pratique
Myriam révolone d'abord vous êtes
philosophe et professeur émérite des
universités à l'École pratique des
hautes études spécialiste de philosophie
éthiques et politiques vous avez abordé
des problèmes liés aux perspectives
philosophiques et politiques actuelles
vous avez signé de nombreux essais
remarqués j'en cite seulement
quelques-uns l'homme compassionnel
pourquoi nous n'aimons pas la démocratie
la crise sans fin essaie sur
l'expérience moderne du temps ou encore
l'esprit du macronisme ou l'art de
dévoyer les concepts tous Paris au seuil
et vous allez signer plusieurs articles
aussi d'un dopage et contribuer
notamment au volume collectif d'une
certaine idée de l'Europe qui est
toujours à libérer chez Flammarion c'est
un texte remarquable intitulé l'Europe
entre sens et non sens
Thierry Chopin en plus d'être aussi une
signature régulière du grand continent
et d'avoir contribué avec un rapport
important au succès de la présidence
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne vous êtes conseiller spécial
de l'Institut Jacques Delors professeur
invité au Collège d'Europe à Bruges et
vous enseignez également à mille-paris
PSL vous êtes l'une des personnalités
européennes qu'on ne présente plus parce
que je viens quand même de faire vos
nombreux ouvrages articles ce lien
européenne font référence je cite
uniquement la fracture politique de
l'Europe je pourrais ici passer beaucoup
plus de temps enfin Klaus veley
personnalité intellectuelle parce que
désormais vous faites un cours à l'école
même un supérieur mais surtout
institutionnel politique allemande de
premier plan vous avez été secrétaire
général du Parlement européen de 2009 à
2022 après avoir été chef de cabinet du
président du Parlement européen de 2007
à 2009 vous êtes aussi conseillé pour le
sintank transatlantique lui a piano
ryzen et vous préparez un texte de fond
fort à propos sur l'état de la
démocratie européenne apparaître dans
nos pages très prochainement
avant de laisser la parole à nos
intervenants et une interventions de
notre ami Jean-Baptiste blanc nous
voulions avoir une pincée pour Pierre
aux invalon qui n'a finalement pu être
là ce soir en raison de motifs impérieux
et qui vous prie Monsieur le Président
chers lecteur devient vouloir un excuser
les interventions seront comme désormais
le format suivi d'un échange avec la
salle avant les mots de conclusion du
président du Sénat et je vous remercie
donc encore et j'ai l'honneur de passer
la parole à Jean-Baptiste blanc
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président chergara anarchie
messieurs mesdames Messieurs les
Présidents de mes chers collègues et
cher tout est chers tous en vos gratte
titre et qualités
[Musique]
parce que c'est grâce à lui que nous
sommes là c'est Gilles Kepel qui
effectivement m'a parlé du grand
continent de Gilles Mathéo je vais
appeler par leur prénom parce
qu'entre-temps on a sympathisé et je
n'étais qu'un modesteur parce que
ensuite nous sommes allés voir Gérard
Larcher qui a tout de suite dit oui pour
que puisse se tenir ce ces rencontres et
je crois que le succès de ce soir et le
deuxième succès déjà à mettre votre
actif montre que nous avons bien fait et
on va profiter de ce succès pour
demander à notre président d'avoir
l'hémicycle à la fois prochaine pour non
soyez d'accord dans l'hémicycle comme ça
on aura j'allais missycle et puis
ensuite la possibilité d'accueillir
encore plus de
d'étudiants voilà d'étudiants et
et de passionnés de ce que vous faites
alors j'aurais pu je comptais moi aussi
partir dans ma litanie des crises et des
disjonctions du moment mais je crois que
ça a été dit et beaucoup mieux que moi
donc je vais les abréger effectivement
beaucoup des observateurs de notre temps
sont très pessimistes et ont tendance à
dire que nous serions au terme de notre
route alors pas celle de kairouac mais
celle de kormak McCarthy que ce serait
peut-être la fin de la partie prédite
par Samuel Beckett et effectivement au
Sénat c'est peut-être aussi l'occasion
de le dire nous sommes pas insensibles
c'est questionnements loin de là et nous
demandons sans cesse comment nous
inscrire dans ces nouvelles temporalité
de toute évidence les institutions
n'auront de salut que s'ils sont justes
et que si elles sont capables de faire
dialoguer les démocraties d'en haut et
les démocraties d'en bas selon le titre
d'un essai que j'ai trouvé assez
lumineux que j'ai lu récemment d'Olivier
Mongin
qui recommande fortement d'appréhender
le plus réalisme ambiant la multitude et
l'individu d'aujourd'hui pour faire une
nouvelle communauté politique et
retrouver ainsi une nouvelle autorité
pour ne pas dire légitimité alors fidèle
à son histoire le Sénat français peut
jouer pour nous président a appelé ce
rôle constitutif et constituant cela ne
peut jamais faire de mal que de revenir
à Anna rent qui rappelle qu'à Rome
repose tout repose sur l'ancienneté des
sénateurs
Olivier Mangin précisément à nouveau en
exégète de Paul ricer nous dit ainsi que
si le pouvoir est dans le peuple et
l'autorité dans le Sénat le pouvoir
politique doit alors se trouver au
croisement de des deux axes vertical et
horizontales de même que le peuple est
comme Agora et le Sénat comme assemblé
les anciens ce qui revient à faire le
lien entre hiérarchie fondation et
mémoire notre cella notre Sénat pardon
comme lieu de plusieurs mémoires comme
lieu de raison que l'on peut opposer
aisément à une certaine forme de passion
dangereuse du moment à l'Assemblée
nationale n'est le Sénat est bel et bien
une vigie de notre temps de Claire
obscure ne connaissant pas pour
l'instant les dérives identitaires et
populistes du moment c'est ça qu'apporte
le Sénat en ce moment le Sénat est
représentatif
s'appuyant encore sur le ciment commune
et sur ses milliers d'élus locaux qui
sont autant de hussard noir de la
République bien que sans cesse attaquer
ces terroirs et ses territoires ton père
notamment les ardeurs métropolitaines
que l'on retrouve dans l'autre chambre
c'est à dire l'Assemblée nationale le
Sénat est représentatif parce que
diversifié il rajeunit il est féminisé
il est transparent et il est exemplaire
quoi quoi qu'on en dise il n'a plus de
privilège il est au cœur des grands
textes du moment le président en a
rappelé mais c'est le Sénat c'est au
Sénat que la loi climat et résilience a
été votée c'est là qu'elle progresse
puisqu'on travaille sur les textes et
qui en sont la suite la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG aussi
c'est ici c'est ici que ça s'est que ça
s'est passé nous avons travaillé hier
soir je pourrais donner des dizaines
d'exemples mais sur le phénomène
mondialisé des fraudes fiscales aux
dividendes voilà qui est un débat
extrêmement contemporain c'est ici que
ça s'est passé pour nous le Sénat est un
meilleur juriste parce qu'il a attaché
au liberté publique il est un meilleur
régulateur nous pourrons en parler il
exerce pleinement son devoir de contrôle
on ne citera que l'exemple de la crise
sanitaire c'est ici que le contrôle
s'est passé l'affaire mckinsee qui parle
à chacun c'est ici aussi que ça s'est
passé le Sénat fait vivre la séparation
des pouvoirs chers à permanent donc la
démocratie française peut-être est-ce
qu'il pourrait se voir renforcer
puisqu'il y a un chantier qu'on nous
annonce sur les institutions dans son
pouvoir d'initiative législatives qui
lui permettrait au Sénat d'enfant faire
de la décentralisation qui nous est très
chère une réalité dans notre pays
puisque tel n'est toujours pas le cas
alors pour terminer
je pense nous pensons que le Sénat a
donc ce paradoxe de la modernité qui a
été évoqué par Emmanuel de vareskiel et
il peut avoir ce pouvoir de commencement
donc parlera sans doute Myriam
c'était un de vos ouvrages je crois
MERCI aux grands continents donc de
permettre cette discussion ces
discussions ces discussions croisées qui
sont fondamentales entre les lieux de
savoir et les lieux de pouvoir pour
tenter de définir les nouvelles voies de
la responsabilité et de l'action
politique je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup cher Jean-Baptiste nous
sommes tous assez impatients je pense
cher Myriam revaudalon de vous entendre
sur ce propos sur la démocratie comme
expérience la parole est à vous
je prendrai
faute de temps nous avons pas beaucoup
de temps pour poser un certain nombre de
questions fondamentales je prendrai un
point de vue un peu latéral par rapport
à l'intitulé de cette rencontre centrée
sur le rôle des parlements face aux
crises qui affectent les démocraties
européennes et en fait je préfère une
remarque fondamentale qui va en
entraîner des autres la question c'est
de quoi est-ce qu'on parle quand on
parle de démocratie
et si je parle d'expérience démocratique
ou de démocratie comme expérience
c'est parce que la démocratie ne se
réduit pas à un système
juridico-politique
qu'elle n'est pas seulement un mode de
gouvernement ou un régime au sens étroit
du terme c'est à dire un certain mode de
répartition d'organisation d'exercices
du pouvoir bien sûr un certain nombre
d'éléments de structure
institutionnelles sont fondamentaux
l'existence d'un état de droit la
séparation ou plutôt l'équilibre des
pouvoirs plus conformes l'idée et à
l'inspiration dans Montesquieu la
présence des contres pouvoirs tout ceci
est absolument essentiel mais la
démocratie c'est aussi comme le disait
Tocqueville dans la démocratie en
Amérique une forme de société
et une forme de société cela implique
des dispositions subjectives propres à
l'homo-démocratique c'est-à-dire une
manière d'être et de vivre ou de ne pas
vivre ensemble un style d'existence des
mœurs des assises mentales et affectives
c'est en ce sens que la démocratie est
une expérience qui englobe à la fois les
pratiques de pouvoir et des positions
subjectives en particulier la démocratie
c'est ce régime paradoxal où la
contradiction publique des actions du
pouvoir est considérée comme légitime
on doit être attentif aux institutions
mais à la condition de considérer que la
démocratie c'est d'abord un mode
d'existence qui ne se réduit pas à la
sanction électorale et à des formes
strictement produirables la démocratie
représentative ne signifie pas que les
citoyens doivent rester silencieux après
avoir voté et en attendant la prochaine
élection à côté de l'élection il garde
la possibilité de s'exprimer de
contester de délibérer et surtout d'être
entendu
car la représentation électorale ce
n'est pas un simple transfert qui remet
ce n'est pas une délégation pure récente
qui remet la volonté des citoyens entre
les mains de leurs élus une fois que les
citoyens ont voté ils ne cessent pas
pour autant d'exercer leur capacités
politiques et c'est précisément la
caractéristique des régimes qu'on
appelle il libéraux que de mettre la
puissance d'agir des citoyens à la
disposition des chefs qu'ils ont
désignés et dans une démocratie digne de
ce nom la liberté de l'opinion publique
implique le droit des gouvernés à
exprimer à tout moment leurs opinions
politiques et leurs protestations
Benjamin Constant on ne saurait
soupçonné d'être tenté par le chaos
politique et le désordre social
insistait sur la nécessité je cite d'une
surveillance active et constante
exercée par le peuple sur ses
représentants en dehors du suffrage de
la liberté chez les modernes mais tout
n'est pas qu'à faire de procédures ou
tout n'est pas seulement à faire de
procédures la démocratie au sens plein
du terme implique que les citoyens se
représentent et s'éprouvent de manière
réflexive comme des acteurs politiques
afin de disposer véritablement d'une
force alternative ce qui fait que la
démocratie est toujours dans une
position instable menacée de deux façons
soit que le lieu soit que les dirigeants
prétendent incarner dans leur personne
le pouvoir du peuple soit que le lieu du
pouvoir
apparaissent aux citoyens comme un lieu
vide accaparé par les très particulier
et c'est là que nous devons faire
intervenir un certain nombre d'éléments
relatifs à la crise et qui déborde de
beaucoup l'idée de gouvernement et qui
nous permettent de comprendre
aujourd'hui ce qui se joue quand on
évoque la crise des démocraties
contemporaine donc très rapidement sur
la question de la crise donc il serait
hors de propos de développer les tenants
et les adoucisses les aboutissants je ne
m'étendrai pas sur un certain nombre de
constats récurrents bien connu la montée
de la défiance des citoyens à l'égard
les institutions des représentants le
déficit général de légitimité qui se
traduit notamment par la montée de
l'abstention la désaffection à l'égard
des mots traditionnelle etc etc donc on
a un certain nombre de signes
extrêmement divers
non seulement de l'essoufflement
démocratique mais d'une crise très
profonde or cette crise et c'est le
propre de la notion de crise ne relève
pas simplement d'un constat objectif
elle engage la subjectivité elle engage
les positions subjectives des individus
leur perception ce qu'ils éprouvent si
je me réfère au sondage déjà très ancien
enfin ancien publié par Le Monde en
novembre 2016 et par le sévi-pof plus
récemment en mars 2020
l'enquête sur le à propos du baromètre
de la confiance politique non seulement
une majorité de français estime que la
démocratie fonctionne de moins en moins
bien l'appréciation n'est certes pas
nouvelle et vous avez rappelé la phrase
de sortie qui est une matrice de la
réflexion sur la démocratie sauf que en
général on ne cite pas la dernière
partie de la phrase qui est aussi dit la
démocratie et le moins mauvais de tous
les régimes à l'exception de tous ceux
qui ont été expérimentés dans l'histoire
donc expérimenter le mot n'est peut-être
pas neutre quand on envisage il y a
démocratie comme comme expérience et il
y a quelque chose d'un petit peu
comment dire préoccupant dans le
résultat de ces derniers sondages qui
est que loin de considérer que la
démocratie est irremplaçable un certain
nombre une grande majorité de
l'individus envisagent de manière
positive les bénéfices possibles d'un
gouvernement technocratique qui serait
guidés par des experts ça irait beaucoup
plus vite et on s'éviterait c'est comme
à dire c'est pérégrination absolument
comme on va dire
sans fin et ou même d'un système
autoritaire où les contre-pouvoirs de
freineraient plus l'action de l'exécutif
donc ces appréciations subjectives
marquent quand même une inflexion
relativement récente parce qu'elle
témoignent de la fin d'un consensus où
tous ou presque tous se proclamaient
démocrates en dépit de leurs
insatisfactions de leur déception et de
leur critique mais c'est le troisième et
dernier point je voudrais souligner on
assiste aussi à des mouvements inverse à
des tentatives de
réappropriation de la capacité citoyenne
qui témoigne d'une prise de conscience
la prise du conscience du fait que la
démocratie n'est pas une forme politique
comme une autre
si nous la préférons si nous la
privilégions c'est précisément qu'elle
répond à une exigence fondamentale que
les individus puissent être à la fois
sujet capable d'obéissance civique et
citoyen agissant libre et égaux comme le
disait le Rousseau être à la fois sujet
et citoyen ou encore obéir à la loi que
l'on sait soi-même prescrite en ce sens
la démocratie est comme le disait aussi
Spinoza le régime qui permet
d'actualiser la puissance d'agir des
hommes qui permet d'actualiser leur
puissance collective elle actualise
l'idée que le pouvoir ne réside pas
seulement dans un rapport vertical entre
ceux qui commandent et ceux qui
obéissent mais qu'il est aussi comme le
disait Anna Arendt un agir ensemble qui
n'appartient à personne personne des
détenteurs de la souveraineté du peuple
ce qui
occupe le lieu du pouvoir ils sont
locataires et non propriétaires doivent
être certes respectées en tant que tel
mais ils ne peuvent prétendre incarner à
eux seuls la légitimité démocratique
et c'est à la lumière de ces réflexions
via la question des parlements que doit
être réenvisager la question de la
représentation puisque c'est ça qui est
au cœur de notre discussion de ce soir
elle ne consiste pas simplement
à être représenté ce n'est pas
simplement être représenté à la voix
passive
être représentée par ses représentants
mais elle met en jeu le fait de se
représenter soi-même de nous représenter
nous-mêmes de manière réflexive comme
citoyen agissant et de nous reconnaître
comme tel c'est cette conscience
réflexive qui évidemment entraîne
l'attention portée au rôle des
parlements des corps intermédiaires et
les associations mais aussi de tous les
acteurs de la société civile et
syndicale et ces deux cette conception
de la représentation que procède les
résistances à la verticalisation du
pouvoir c'est pourquoi à côté du rythme
ou des scans si on veut électorales la
dynamique démocratique implique à la
fois des modalités de contestation
d'expression des désaccords et des
modalités de participation qui
accompagnent nécessairement la
revolarisation du rôle des parlements
donc je pense que à la fois nous
percevons aujourd'hui dans la crise qui
nous touche un certain nombre de choses
très graves qui portent atteintes à la
dynamique démocratique et sa créativité
mais à contrario je dirais que le fait
d'envisager la démocratie non pas
simplement comme un ensemble procédural
les communes dynamique comme une
invention comme disait Claude Lefort
nous conduit au-delà des procédures
institutionnelles déjà existantes et
nous ne pouvons nous éprouver nous-mêmes
comme citoyen agissant que si nous
retrouvons le sens de l'invention
démocratique c'est dans cette
perspective pour moi que s'inscrit la
question de la représentation et du rôle
des parlements c'est à dire imaginer
des procédures qui organiseraient les
pratiques démocratiques sur le plan
institutionnel et qui organise qui
organiseraient des actions citoyennes
répondant à cette dynamique voilà je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup mes rêves Thierry Chopin
je vous donne la parole vous remercier
encore une fois pour votre amitié et
d'avoir répondu présent en même temps si
court vous avez proposé de parler à une
dizaine de minutes donc je salue votre
courage sur les évolutions de
transformation des institutions
démocratiques européennes au cours des
15 dernières années et des crises de
l'Union européenne donc la parole est à
vous pour 10 minutes merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Gilles bonsoir à toutes
et à tous merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour votre accueil au sein de
la Haute Assemblée je vais essayer de
faire un pas de côté finalement par
rapport à ce que vient de dire Myriam
revaudalon et notamment peut-être en
focalisant mon propos sur la dimension
peut-être de la démocratie comme forme
comme forme politique ou
institutionnelle et par ailleurs
peut-être un deuxième pas de côté en
abordant cette question à l'échelle
européenne
le sujet portait sur la démocratie
européenne face aux crises et je pour ma
part de la démocratie de l'Union
européenne plus plus spécifiquement de
manière à recentrer la focale je
voudrais faire essentiellement deux
séries de remarques dans les 10 minutes
que tu as bien voulu me donner d'abord
peut-être effectivement tirer quelques
leçons des 15 années de crise qui
viennent de s'écouler pour la
gouvernance de l'Union européenne je
crois qu'il y a des leçons qu'on peut en
tirer qui sont intéressantes pour pour
analyser l'équilibre ou plutôt les
déséquilibres entre le pouvoir exécutif
européen et la dimension parlementaire
de l'Union européenne et puis je ferai
une seconde série de remarques peut-être
davantage centrée sur sur la France en
tout cas du point de vue de son
organisation institutionnelle en matière
de politique européenne avec quelques
pistes peut-être d'ailleurs de
propositions susceptibles de vous
intéresser en matière de renforcement de
la responsabilité de l'exécutif
vis-à-vis du Parlement dans dans ce
domaine sur le premier point d'abord
quelques leçons sur les 15 ans de crise
qui viennent de s'écouler vous l'avez
monsieur le Président rappelé depuis
l'Union européenne a été confrontée à un
certain nombre de crises qui se sont qui
se sont enchaînés après lesquels on a on
a couru en réalité et ces crises en fait
d'ailleurs qu'on peut qu'on pourrait
qualifier de choc de souveraineté elle
touche toute à des enjeux régaliens
d'une manière ou d'une autre toutes ces
crises finalement ont d'abord eu
peut-être des vertus positives au sens
où elles ont provoqué une mobilisation
politique hors norme au plus haut niveau
des États au niveau chef d'État et
gouvernement vous avez mentionné la
montée en puissance du Conseil européen
non pas dans le triangle institutionnel
communautaire mais dans le quadrilatère
finalement que représente la gouvernance
de l'Union européenne aujourd'hui et
effectivement cette montée en puissance
des chefs d'État de gouvernement sans
doute s'explique par deux fondamental
d'abord la légitimité politique de ce
chef d'État et de gouvernement face à de
tels enjeux et par ailleurs le fait que
les États disposent de moyens
budgétaires évidemment qui ne sont pas
ceux de l'Union européenne en tant que
tel en même temps si je puis dire
cette montée en puissance du Conseil
européen a eu des conséquences
ambivalentes voire négatives me
semble-t-il au moins pour ce qui
concerne les crises entre 2008 et 2015
dans la mesure où ce qu'on a pu
percevoir c'est un certain nombre
d'effets négatifs de cette gouvernance
de crise par les chefs d'État de
gouvernement lenteur de la négociation
diplomatique d'abord
incertitude lié à la désynchronisation
des moments politiques nationaux en
Europe qui entraîne en fait une
difficulté d'abord à se mettre d'accord
mais même le cas échéant quand on
parvient à se mettre d'accord au niveau
des chefs d'État de gouvernement la
possibilité que les décisions prises
puissent être remises en cause du fait
d'un changement de gouvernement d'un
changement de majorité dentelle ou tel
État membre
sans doute les crises plus récentes je
pense à la crise du covid je pense
également à la guerre en Ukraine
permettent de dire qu'on a peut-être
tiré commencé à tirer des leçons des
effets négatifs de cette gouvernance de
crise par
le Conseil européen en tout cas on a
pris moins de temps à prendre les
décisions qui qui s'imposaient mais à
nouveau on voit bien que le véritable
souverain c'est la nécessité
ça ne relève pas en réalité d'un choix
de type démocratique au sens où ce choix
cette décision aurait fait l'objet au
préalable d'un débat informé au sein
d'enceintes parlementaire comme on est
en droit de l'attente de l'attendre
pardon quand on est en démocratie sans
parler effectivement de ce que vous avez
mentionné également l'usage d'un certain
nombre de dispositions juridiques des
traités je pense à l'article 122 du
traité de l'Union européenne mais dont
parlera sans doute Klaus vélo dans un
instant
qui a tendance à mettre entre
parenthèses le rôle du Parlement
européen dans cette gestion de crise
même si l'urgence en fait à nouveau nous
contraint à prendre les décisions en
question donc politique de l'urgence
politique de l'événement si on veut
reprendre une expression des désormais
célèbre
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
et en réalité qui me semble poser deux
problèmes fondamentaux le premier en
terme d'efficacité le second en termes
de légitimité le mot est souvent revenu
dans les présentations et les discours
qui qui viennent d'être prononcé sur le
registre de l'efficacité d'abord ce qui
est très frappant c'est que finalement
certains observateurs certains acteurs
se satisfont en réalité de du fait que
le Conseil européen cette rayon des
chefs d'État de gouvernement soit devenu
serait devenu j'utilise le conditionnel
le véritable pouvoir exécutif de l'Union
européenne sous une forme très
particulière comme un pouvoir exécutif
collectif c'est sans doute vrai
empiriquement mais par contre est-ce que
ça règle le problème de l'efficacité de
la légitimité des réponses apportées aux
crises au niveau européen je ne crois
pas du tout donc je sais pas en total
accord avec la thèse de quelqu'un qui
faut lire comme Luc Van medler à cet
égard il y a d'autres lectures qui me
semblent également intéressantes je
pense d'ailleurs à des travaux qui ont
été rendus accessibles en français par
le grand continent ceux de Jonathan
white notamment qui qui consacre des
développements importants à cette
question de de la politique de l'urgence
le problème en termes d'efficacité de ce
caractère collectif ou fragmenté
finalement
de ce pouvoir exécutif que quelqu'un
aurait le Conseil européen
c'est que finalement encore une fois ça
produit cette cette relative lenteur
même dans la gestion des crises récentes
même dans la gestion la crise sanitaire
les premiers mois finalement sont des
mois où on attendait une décision ce à
quoi on a assisté c'est un étalage de
division nationale entre les États on
avait tiré malgré tous les leçons de la
crise de la zone euro 10 ans plus tôt et
on a réussi à surmonter cette difficulté
liée à ce caractère fragmenté et
collectif du Conseil européen
je crois que sur cette question
d'ailleurs du pouvoir exécutif même sous
une forme collective j'y pense
évidemment en écho à ce que disait
Myriam et ce qui a été dit d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises dans les discourss
luminaires c'est la difficulté au niveau
européen d'identifier de localiser où se
situe en réalité le véritable foyer
d'autorité vous avez utilisé ce mot
monsieur le Président dans votre
discours
et là je crois que c'est un véritable
question qui montre que le système de
gouvernance rationnel de l'Union
européenne ne répond peut-être pas au
les plus classiques d'un système de si
ce n'est de séparation stricte des
pouvoirs comme on pourrait le trouver
aux États-Unis au moins d'équilibre des
pouvoirs
on a davantage à faire un système de
d'équilibre des intérêts en réalité qui
caractérise cette gouvernance là
deuxième deuxième difficulté qui ne
semble découler
de ce de cette gestion de crise
finalement où le Conseil européen d'un
point de vue politique en tout cas et
central je mets à part la Banque
centrale européenne évidemment dans dans
cette dans ce dans cette analyse même
très très rapide la question de la
légitimité finalement la question du
Kratos dans un premier cas dans le
premier temps et puis la question du
demos dans dans le second ce qui me
semble aussi frappant c'est que dans le
système actuel on a davantage à faire un
système qu'on pourrait appeler
diplocratique et non pas démocratique au
sens le plus fondamental du terme parce
que là encore
cette fragmentation des diplomaties
nationales au sein du Conseil européen
produit non seulement un certain nombre
de problèmes en termes d'efficacité mais
aussi en termes de légitimité je crois
que cette fragmentation elle conduit à
une dilution de la responsabilité des
acteurs politiques finalement quand on
dit le Conseil européen a pris tel
décision de qui on parle en fait
fondamentalement est-ce qu'on est
capable d'imputer la responsabilité de
la décision
à telle ou telle chef d'État du
gouvernement étant entendu évidemment
que juridiquement et formellement chacun
d'entre eux ou chacune d'entre eux
d'entre elles ont une égalité de droit
mais que dans la réalité l'influence
politique diplomatique de telle ou telle
chef d'État de gouvernement peut-être
différent en fonction des États membres
dont on parle donc dilution de la
responsabilité et puis une question qui
me semble aussi fondamentale même si je
m'aventure sur un terrain qui est
peut-être pas le mien un terrain de
philosophie politique donc je parle sous
le contrôle de Myriam revaudalon à cet
égard il me semble que ce degré de
fragmentation aussi
conduit imposer une question qui est
fondamentale quand on évoque la question
de la représentation politique c'est la
question du mandat politique et du
mandat démocratique or il me semble que
la question fondamentale que pose la
centralité la primauté du Conseil
européen en cette gestion de crise c'est
comment définir ce mandat politique et
démocratique à cette échelle européenne
là est-ce que pour le dire dans des
termes peut-être plus simple plus
basique l'addition de 27 légitimités
politiques nationales de 27 mandats
politiques nationaux produisent une
légitimité politique européenne et un
mandat politique européen
personnellement je pense que la réponse
est NON et donc on doit effectivement
réfléchir aux modalités
institutionnelles capables de produire
ce mandat politique et cette légitimité
démocratique
si j'ai encore un petit peu le temps je
en deux minutes ou trois trois minutes
alors sous forme de conclusion deuxième
peut-être série de remarques très brève
sur la France parce que je pense que la
question qui nous était posée se pose à
la fois à l'échelle européenne mais
évidemment à l'échelle nationale
peut-être deux deux choses même de
manière schématique pour pour la
discussion
après les interventions il me semble que
d'abord selon ton a besoin dans notre
pays en matière de politique européenne
c'est d'un exécutif qui soit plus
responsable effectivement devant le
Parlement alors je suis je suis pas
complètement naïf et je sais très bien
que
les prérogatives constitutionnels du
président en matière d'action extérieure
et notamment en matière d'action
européenne font que le président n'est
pas comptable en tout cas de manière
claire de son action devant les
enceintes parlementaires ce qui pose
évidemment un problème mais qu'on
pourrait régler que par une modification
de la Constitution mais en tout cas je
voulais au moins soulever ce paradoxe
que le Président de la République est
affranchi également de tout compte à
rendre devant le Parlement français
devant lequel finalement il n'a pas le
droit de se rendre alors même que le
Président de la République peut aller
faire un discours au Parlement européen
et donc s'exprimer devant des euros
députés français au sein de l'assemblée
de Strasbourg peut-être évidemment sauf
à modifier la Constitution une
alternative pourrait être peut-être
envisageable deux pistes à cet égard
même de manière très brève la première
peut-être permettre au Premier ministre
de participer au Conseil européen c'est
tout à fait possible juridiquement ça se
fait en période de cohabitation mais on
pourrait élargir évidemment dans des
périodes or cohabitation ce dispositif
je pense que ça présente beaucoup
d'avantages permettent de rendre compte
de l'action européenne en fait au
parlementaire d'abord
plus grande cohérence aussi
institutionnelle dans la mesure
évidemment le Premier ministre a
autorité sur le scrutinat général des
affaires européennes
et dans la mesure où Gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation il semblerait normal évidemment
que dans une enceinte où des décisions
importantes pour la politique européenne
de notre pays pour nous concitoyens sont
prises que le premier ministre puisse
participer à ces réunions et à ses
négociations la deuxième chose pour
terminer peut-être sur sur ce volet il
pourrait être aussi intéressant
d'imaginer l'organisation d'un discours
annuel du président de la République
devant le Congrès ce qui permettrait de
fournir de provoquer finalement une
occasion de discussion entre le
Président de la République et les
parlementaires français sur les sujets
et les enjeux européens et puis ça
pourrait constituer évidemment aussi un
moment important d'information politique
pour les citoyens il faudrait réfléchir
d'ailleurs peut-être dans cette
perspective à articuler le plus finement
possible ce discours
potentiel du président devant le Congrès
avec le discours sur l'état de l'Union
de la présidente de la Commission
européenne
voilà j'aurais bien d'autres choses à
dire mais le temps est compté merci
beaucoup de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup cher cher
Thierry Chopin pour cette mise en
perspective effectivement et ses
propositions très intéressantes sans
plus tarder je vais passer la parole à
Klaus vélo pour là encore une mise en
perspective et je dirais qui nous
intéresse d'autant plus que nous sommes
pratiquement à un an d'une autre séance
démocratique importante les élections
européennes de 2024 donc là vous avez le
pour un propos sur le Parlement européen
donc vous avez été secrétaire général on
l'a rappelé face aux crises bilan et
perspectives un an avant les élections
européennes pour une dizaine de minutes
avant de poursuivre l'échange avec la
salle merci
beaucoup et aussi merci beaucoup pour
cette invitation
peut-être avant que je commence avec mon
discours une très remarque parce que on
a discuté beaucoup sur le Conseil
européen mais je me souviens très bien
que c'était une initiative français dans
le temps c'était très lié au nom de
Giscard d'Estaing et je me souviens
encore qu'on ne parlementaire sont
revenus de la dernière réunion de la
convention ils étaient très frustrés
parce que presque tous les membres de la
Convention se sont exprimés contre
l'Institut scénarisation du Conseil
européen et il paraît je n'étais pas là
que Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing aurait
répondu mais moi je peux voir des
majorités futures
et donc c'est resté dans le texte donc
il me paraît aussi dans cette balade qui
est des questions européennes et des
questions françaises des questions et
peut-être problème dans l'institution
française se marie un peu dans cette
dans cette base ici
mais pour ma contribution
donc d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est une crise et
peut-être là il s'exprime aussi un peu
le tempérament
à moi une crise c'est qu'on le status
quo
ne peut plus être maintenu
une crise c'est quand le changement
devient finalement une obligation
une crise c'est quand le nouveau reçoit
finalement ça change
on dit que la crise et l'heure de
l'exécutif
peut-être
la crise est plutôt le moment de ceux
qui ont anticipé
qui ont une idée du futur
qui sont prêts à agir et vite
c'est leurs idées
qui vont déterminer le chemin à prendre
quand finalement le rapport n'est plus
possible
les exécutifs et leurs appareils
aiment les parlements comme chambre
d'appui
réactif
il est séduisant d'oublier que la
légitimité finalement vient du peuple et
le leur représentant démocratiquement
élu
les parlementes doivent donc être avant
agile et indépendamment indépendant dans
leur réflexion
c'est donc très important que le travail
journalier
ne domine pas le tout
il faut donner systématiquement une
place
au futur dans la réflexion
et dans l'action du Parlement
comment le faire en pratique
les parlements le mot à dire dans les
cycles législatifs et politiques
celui-ci qui va déterminer l'agenda
a déjà décidé
ce 80% du résultat
le Parlement européen a développé des
outils pour y arriver à long terme
à mi-temps et à court terme
l'élection du président de la Commission
européenne par le Parlement européen
tout au commencement de la législature
est une négociation qui prend des
semaines
le Parlement européenne est une
institution
composée de minorité
même si la candidate comme actuellement
était sûr de la plus grande famille
politique
cela signe dispose de plus de 25% des
sièges
le soutien des parlementaires des autres
groupes politiques lors de l'élection
dépend donc des concessions sur le
contenu à mettre en œuvre
pendant les longues cinq ans de la
législature
les crises évidentes et prévisibles
comme le réchauffement climatique
peuvent donc y être adressés d'une
manière précise et concrète
cette occasion se répète lors des
confirmations des candidats commissaires
individuels
dans son ensemble
et permet d'adresser des questions
sectorielles et plus en détail
depuis la présidente du Parlement par
l'ancien Premier ministre
polonaise chez Boussac
l'institution dispose de l'instrument
pour actualiser ses accords dans une
perspective à mi-temps
le grand débat parlementaire avec la
présidente de la Commission européenne
chaque automne qui s'appelle l'état de
l'Union
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est pas
seulement un discours mais avant que la
présidente donne son discours elle va
bien sûr
consulter les différentes acteurs
politiques pour voir qu'est-ce qu'il
fait le soutien
et dans le vif
le Parlement européen a fait
démonstration pendant la crise du covid
qu'elle était capable de faire
fonctionner une démocratie continentale
et multinationale de 27 pays de plus que
440 millions de citoyens en digital et
en distance
elle a pu jouer un rôle
clé dans la solidarité
en poussant pour le programme multimédia
nouvelle génération l'Union européenne
le Parlement européenne était le premier
à pouvoir saluer le président
ukrainien Céline ski on débats
sa présidente Roberta metzola la
première chef d'une institution
européenne à se rendre à Kiev
les députés en avant du conseil de la
Commission européenne en demandant la
perspective de l'accès de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne
le Parlement européen a joué un rôle
décisif on assurant que les crises en
Europe ne sont pas devenus des crises de
l'Union européenne
est-ce qu'il y a donc plus rien à faire
la permacrise de dernières années nous
montre bien que l'ordre international
est en train de est en train de changer
fondamentalement
l'agressivité russe contre les civils en
Syrie
provoquant la déstabilisation de la
politique en Europe par le flux de
millions des réfugiés et maintenant saga
contre l'Ukraine ont mis fin à 30 ans de
coopération paisible
la confrontation entre la Chine et les
États-Unis
s'accélère d'une manière dangereuse
et va restructurer les relations
politiques et économiques mondialement
on risque fort
d'entrer pas seulement dans une nouvelle
guerre froide mais peut-être même une
guerre chaude
le paradigme du prix
déterminant depuis la chute de l'Union
soviétique et maintenant remplacer par
un nouveau paradigme de sécurité
et la compétition de ce système
politique
il est donc
urgent d'améliorer nos capacités
d'analyse
et des risques
les services recherchent du Parlement
européen
a développé pendant les dernières 10 ans
les outils qui nous soutiennent dans
cette ambition
la revitalisation de l'idée du coût de
l'anonorock soutenu par des centaines de
pages d'analyses mais en avance les
opportunités inachevées des croissances
sont dettes
le travail sur le récitémique très
probable à se réaliser et les capacités
disponibles ou non à les maîtriser
en forme sur un programme amitaire pour
éviter les crises les plus graves et
soutenir la résilience
la coopération entre institutionnelle
espaces commencez à l'initiative du
Parlement européenne par rapport à la
menteur de la commission du budget
rapporteur était le député James ls au
plus haut niveau administratif sur le
train globaux à établi une base solide
qui a facilité la création d'un
vice-président de la Commission
européenne
responsable pour la prévision
les réunions de ministres du futur et
l'établissement du centre d'expertise
dans toutes les institutions en bref les
structures de prévisions
les crises ne doivent pas nécessairement
être affrontés et ça c'est la méthode
travail du Conseil européen par la
méthode dos contre le mur regarde dans
la bise
dans une nouvelle fonction
j'ai proposé de mettre la soutenabilité
au cœur de tous nos politiques pas
seulement dans l'environnement
centre on propose une programme d'action
de 175 mesures sur les 7 d et c'est ça
les questions où je pense que
l'équilibre n'est plus n'est plus là la
défense
la dette la démocratie la démocratie le
digital la décapbonisation
et la déclobalisation c'est ce que
Madame fanaline appelle DIY
la crise c'est aussi le résultat d'une
montre d'action merci
merci beaucoup à tous les trois c'est
intéressant était très riche je suis sûr
qu'il y a beaucoup de réactions et de
questions nous ouvrons pendant une
vingtaine de minutes les interventions
les échanges avec le public donc je vous
prie de vous signaler devant la main et
on prendra une série de questions
intervention afin de permettre tous les
trois de répondre donc peut-être
monsieur là-bas
il y a pas de micro perven je béret
peut-être pour commencer et par la suite
merci excusez-moi d'être arrivé en
retard
mais
d'avoir entendu que la fin
d'intervention
de Cloud
dresser ma question car
dans le mot crise il y a une dimension
que vous n'avez pas mentionné qui est la
question de l'urgence et c'est une
question qui
s'inscrit dans l'ensemble du dispositif
institutionnel de l'Union européenne
puisque contrairement à un état régalien
qui est là pour protéger les citoyens
face à la guerre l'Union n'est pas
construite là-dessus et donc son rythme
de production
et de réaction n'est pas construite sur
le court terme sur la crise et c'est
d'autant plus vrai pour le Parlement
européen qui lorsqu'il exerce un pouvoir
l'exerce en tant que collégislateur et
du coup avec un temps de maturation de
négociation d'élaboration de
construction qui est un temps que
l'exécutif par définition considère
comme étant un temps trop long donc et
mais j'ai bien entendu ce que vous avez
dit que le Parlement européen avait bien
réagi notamment sous votre impulsion
pour passer en numérique au moment de la
covid ou de proclamer
que l'Ukraine devait devenir un pays
membres de l'Union européenne mais c'est
pas de ça dont on parle ce dont on parle
c'est ce qui fait que
l'exécutif court-circuite cherche des
méthodes et des outils pour
court-circuiter le Parlement européen
dans le travail de collégislation dès
lors qu'il considère qu'il y a une
urgence donc comment
éviter ça et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
proposer pour
empêcher l'exécutif de fonctionner de
cette manière là qui est une manière qui
au bout du compte creuse un déficit
démocratique dont on n'a pas besoin
merci beaucoup pervers monsieur c'est
peut-être vous pouvez aussi vous
présenter brièvement avant de poser
votre question
je pense que ça se présente pas
bonjour de votre canne fédérale Europe
merci pour les interventions vous avez
très bien indiqué que les grands défis
les grands sujets se traitent désormais
au plan européen d'après les citoyens de
l'Europe et c'est le cas en raison de
l'interdépendance très poussée entre nos
pays et en raison des des risques que
représentent les puissances les
superpuissances et vous avez d'autre
part très bien montré le manque
d'efficacité le manque de prévisibilité
de capacité à prévoir et le manque de
légitimité du Conseil européen qui est
de fait le centre du pouvoir des
institutions européennes
alors la question est très simple dans
ce cadre-là et compte tenu de ces
éléments ne faudra-t-il pas tout
simplement créer un gouvernement
européen fédéral
compétent pour certaines
choses limitées qu'on ne peut plus faire
uniquement en France ou en Allemagne par
exemple le créer avec quelques pays
fondateurs et ce gouvernement fédéral
serait évidemment légitime il serait
plus efficace bien sûr et il aurait la
capacité de prévoir comme peut le faire
le gouvernement américain merci merci
une dernière question de cette série oui
un modèle
j'ajoute juste que cette proposition a
été faite par le gouvernement allemand
et la France pourrait se fixer comme
objectif d'aller dans cette direction
bonjour Guilaine étudiante en droit ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Chopin
justement vous avez parlé du fait que le
Conseil de l'Europe soit une sorte
d'exécutif européen qui agit justement
de manière à pallier les la collégialité
qu'il y a au Parlement seulement est-ce
que là avec tous les toutes les
superpuissances la crise entre la Chine
les États-Unis et que l'Europe se place
un peu au milieu de tout ça est-ce que
justement le Conseil de l'Europe va pas
essayer de
le Parlement plutôt va s'effacer face au
Conseil de l'Europe en vue de répondre
plus rapidement justement à ces crises
différentes voilà merci
si vous voulez commencer en première
série de réponses
en effet je crois la la question de
pervenche Perez mais aussi les
introductions qui étaient faits
à pose la question exactement là où il
faut poser la question parce que là je
crois la description est correcte le
Conseil européen réagit sur les
questions d'État
classiquement les questions régaliennes
comme vous avez dit
et pourquoi est-ce que le Conseil
européen de faire
parce qu'il est devant la nécessité
et pourquoi est-ce que le Conseil le
fait en improvisé parce que c'était pas
réglé correctement dans les traités
ça veut dire il y a
il y a une manière d'adresser aussi le
contrôle démocratique ça veut dire de
d'accepter que au monde où on vit il
faut traiter d'une manière efficace par
exemple la politique être étrangère
sécurité défense au niveau européen si
on est confronté par la Russie et
peut-être confrontée par le chinois et
quelquefois peut-être même confronté par
nos amis à America donc si on a le
courage de le dire de l'accepter on peut
le mettre aussi d'une manière organisée
dans les institutions européennes et à
l'autre côté
il y a le palme il y a le Parlement
nationaux
et
j'ai participé à beaucoup de réunions
avec les présidents de Parlement
nationaux et les secrétaire général et
de mon point de vue le problème
principal c'est que la participation de
Parlement nationaux et très réglé d'une
manière très très différente à tous les
Parlement donc c'est même très difficile
entre le président du Parlement de ce
palais on commence très régulièrement
par les présidents du Parlement qui
disent moi je n'ai pas le droit de
m'exprimer sur les questions politiques
mais on a des modèles qui fonctionnent
les modèles qui fonctionnent sont les
modèles scandinave la grande chambre au
fil Land le contrôle au Danemark si on
veut vraiment faire plus fort la voix
des parlements nationaux il faut il faut
une sorte gold stand up
pour tout le Parlement nationaux dont le
contrôle d'abord de leur propre
gouvernement
qui doit se justifier devant le
Parlement pour les décisions et les
actions que le gouvernement prend au
niveau européen et à ce moment-là on
commence à contrôler aussi l'action et
des décisions prises au cancer européen
qui sont en dehors du cadre du traité
européenne donc le plus bon conseil que
je peux donner au Parlement nationaux ça
c'est de faire du modèle scandina
finnois danois
la pratique utilisée par tout le porno
Parlement nationaux dans le contrôle de
leur exécutive et de demander leurs
exécutives d'accepter d'accepter ça à sa
moment aussi une coopération entre le
parlement national devient possible
parce que si on n'a pas les mêmes si on
n'a pas les mêmes droits ça devient très
très difficile d'agir entre par le monde
nationaux d'une manière ensemble au
niveau européen
c'était pour vous
merci beaucoup pour pour votre question
manière générale je pense que avec le
retour en fait des enjeux de puissance
et des questions géopolitiques
il y a plusieurs choses en fait qui en
découlent d'abord en fait une prise de
conscience de la nécessité de renforcer
notre sécurité et une fois qu'on a dit
ça une deuxième chose c'est
qu'évidemment comme il s'agit de de
sujets régaliens qui sont tous situés au
cœur de la souveraineté de l'État très
clairement le rôle des États et des
chefs d'État de gouvernement notamment
sera central et donc cette institution
qu'elle conseille européen le sera le
sera aussi
néanmoins une fois qu'on a dit ça
peut-être deux choses en matière et pour
faire écho est-ce que Klaus vient de
dire à l'instant en matière de politique
européenne et politique internationale
les modèles en fait des relations entre
pour les gouvernements nationaux et
Parlement nationaux sont très différents
d'un pays membres à l'autre et là il se
trouve qu'on est dans un pays ici en
France où il y a une singularité de ce
point de vue là il y a une relative
fragilité je le dis dans des termes
diplomatiques du contrôle parlementaire
vis-à-vis des prérogatives
constitutionnels en fait de l'exécutif
et notamment du président de la
République en matière d'action
extérieure c'est pas du tout le cas dans
d'autres pays membres effectivement le
modèle danois le modèle allemand aussi
sont des modèles intéressants en fait
assez à cet égard et donc il faut il
faut il faut distinguer en fait les cas
les cas de figures nationaux de ce point
de vue là par ailleurs l'autre chose en
fait qui venait à l'esprit en vous
écoutant poser votre question c'est que
sur ces sujets de sécurité de défense il
y a un enjeu je trouve très fort de
convergence entre les États membres et
il y a un travail de convergence à
réaliser sur différents registres on le
voit évidemment d'abord sur enregistre
stratégique la question de savoir ce
qu'on doit faire en réalité quand on dit
il faut renforcer notre sécurité
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
veut dire la question se pose avec les
milliards d'euros qui sont mis sur la
table en fait aujourd'hui avec les forts
budgétaires en matière de défense est-ce
que ça signifie
renforcer les capacités nationales en
matière de défense est-ce que ça
signifie renforcer et développer des
capacités européennes communes à
l'échelle européenne dans ce domaine
est-ce que ça veut dire renforcer le
pays européen de l'OTAN est-ce que ça
veut dire faire uniquement confiance à
l'autre c'est-à-dire acheter du matériel
sur étagère etc etc donc on voit qu'il y
a un débat très fort sur ce registre
stratégique il y a aussi un débat qui
devrait avoir lieu sur la question sur
le registre politique c'est-à-dire si on
décide d'aller dans une direction qui
nous fait renforcer nos capacités en
matière de sécurité la question de
savoir
et SL en fait la question de savoir
comment à quelles conditions on utilise
finalement c'est capacités là et là
encore entre les différents États
membres les les conditions politiques en
fait pour pour utiliser des moyens de
défense sont pas les mêmes d'un pays
membrane à l'autre et le rôle des
parlements et variable entre les
différents pays européens donc là aussi
il y a un effort de convergence à
réaliser et puis évidemment aussi effort
de convergence sur le plan opérationnel
sur le plan industriel et je pense que
tous ces éléments là de débats de
discussion
doit faire l'objet de débat et de
discussion aussi au sein des enceintes
parlementaires et pas uniquement entre
acteurs des exécutifs nationaux et
européens donc je trouve que même sur
ces sujets alors que ces enjeux sont
régaliens malgré tout les parlements
auront importants à jouer y compris dans
des pays qui singularisent en fait par
la relative faiblesse de leur contrôle
parlementaire vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
merci Myriam bravo vous voulez peut-être
intervenir où on peut ouvrir pour une
autre série de questions comme vous le
souhaitez peut-être une série de
questions encore une dizaine de minutes
alors Bertrand Séné donc je suis
économiste écologiste
et je suis passionné également par les
questions de démocratie
dans la façon dont chacun a présenté les
choses on voit qu'il y a différents
angles d'approche sur les questions
démocratiques et moi il y a un angle qui
me qui me frappe beaucoup et que
j'entends beaucoup qui est que en fait
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat et le
Parlement européen ne sont pas du tout
représentatifs de la diversité de la
population en réalité c'est une minorité
privilégiée dont je fais partie
d'ailleurs qui y est présente et qui
croit savoir ce qu'il faut faire pour le
peuple sans avoir l'expérience concrète
d'un grand nombre de problèmes qui sont
rencontrés par la population comme par
exemple la violence de l'inflation
aujourd'hui
et on imagine que si c'était d'autres
personnes qui étaient dans l'assemblée
on ne prendrait pas les mêmes décisions
par rapport à l'inflation aujourd'hui
en fait face
pour pour prendre des décisions justes
pour le peuple on a besoin de vrais
débats avec une diversité d'opinion et
une diversité d'expérience de vie or
l'appartenance à des partis politiques
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui dégradent
fortement la qualité des débats car elle
réduit la liberté de pensée elle réduit
la liberté de critiquer et la capacité à
changer d'opinion qui est tellement
vital pour rechercher la meilleure
solution possible dans l'intérêt général
face au défi écologique et sociaux il me
semble qu'il est en fait grand temps de
mettre en place une démocratie de
l'intelligence collective beaucoup plus
représentative ce qui implique d'écrire
une nouvelle page de la démocratie
probablement sans parti politique et de
donner plus de place au tirage au sort
et moins aux élections ce qui
permettrait aussi d'accroître la
légitimité et l'acceptabilité des
décisions alors voilà je voulais vous
proposer de de rentrer sur cette
question du tirage au sort et je serai
absolument ravi de participer à un débat
sur les vertus et les vis de l'élection
et du tirage au sort sachant que je vais
bientôt publier un article sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup il y avait une aussi une
question au fond la si vous pouvez vous
présenter brièvement oui bonsoir merci
donc medilate j'ai étudiant à Sciences
Po face à la montée des idéaux extrêmes
sur la scène politique mais aussi des
discours de haine en lien notamment avec
les crises telles que les crises
migratoires ou sanitaires
quel rôle on les Parlement comment
légifertile sans pour autant empiéter
sur nos libertés fondamentales merci
beaucoup c'est une dernière question
tout au fond là-bas
j'en ai peut-être une dernière sur le
fait qu'on soit au Sénat pour parler
d'Europe et du fait qu'on parle
démocratie quand on voit une dynamique
on a une intégration de plus en plus
fort des compétences au niveau de
l'Europe et en même temps une
distribution de plus en plus forte du de
l'action concrète des services publics
par justement cette revendication de
représenter les territoires et de savoir
ce qu'on y fait avec une descente
réalisation dont on peut encore vouloir
l'accélérer comment est-ce que on recrée
justement cette démocratie cette
expérience de la démocratie européenne
quand on a un partage des compétences
qui est encore en évolution
merci beaucoup donc c'est peut-être on
commençait de parclose et on va finir
sur
je vais me concentrer sur la sur la
première question est-ce que le
Parlement européen est représentatif je
crois on est extrêmement représentatif
dont le meilleur et dans le pire
c'est vraiment l'image du continent en
large
mais j'ai eu aussi si ce permis de le
dire l'oppression ici
que peut-être la malaise en France est
aussi liée au fait que des grandes
pourcentages de la population dont la
Cinquième République sont
systématiquement exclus de la
représentation au Parlement peut-être
pour des très bons résultats peut-être
pour de très bons raisons mais ne se
sont pas représentés et donc on voit la
violence
au Parlement on les a tous eu beaucoup
plus tôt on a eu Madame Le Pen au
Parlement européen elle a exécée son
mandat beaucoup de monde
oui
toutes les minorités toutes les pensées
toutes les réflexions trouvent leur
place et peuvent participer à la change
et moi je trouve pour moi ça c'est une
pré condition aussi pour l'acceptation
des résultats
je n'ai pas de comment dire de réponse à
précise à apporter à chacune des
questions mais il me semble que je
préfère une remarque sur ce qui les
motive et ce sont sur leur point de
départ il me semble que toutes les
questions les dernières qui ont été
posées sont l'expression précisément
d'un espèce de malaise
et de la prise de conscience d'un
décalage entre la représentation au sens
procédural du terme et ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure au fond l'esprit la
démocratie ou le fait de se sentir
représenté la question de la
représentativité formelle elle est pas
nouvelle elle se pose comme on va dire
elle s'est posée pour les comment dire
pour le moment de la Révolution
américaine elle s'est posée au moment de
la compagnon de la formation de la
Constituante en France et on sait très
bien que ce qui a été accusé d'emblée
par le théoricien constitué c'est la
représentation miroir parce que ça ça ne
ça ne veut rien dire ça ne fonctionne
pas c'est pas mais d'une certaine façon
au fond il y a il y a dans la
représentation
tant qu'on la conçoit comme une
comment dire une simple délégation ou un
transfert une imperfection ou un vice
fondamentale qui est absolument
insoluble c'est pour cette raison c'est
pour cette raison que
au fond ce type de questions ne peut
être réfléchi ou travailler comme il y
en obtient certainement pas de solutions
parfaites au sens mathématique du terme
et que ce type de question ne peut être
repris que si on désasse ou si on
déborde l'aspect strictement procédural
c'est-à-dire que toutes ces questions
toutes ces questions qui sont posées
elles Témo ignent de la conscience d'un
décalage ou une dissymétrie entre la
démocratie telle qu'elle est mise en
forme elle est nécessairement mise en
forme de façon imparfaite et un esprit
de la démocratie qui ne coïncide jamais
totalement avec elle
peut-être un mot sur un sujet très très
large que vous avez évoqué sur la montée
des extrémismes et notamment des
discours de haine
évidemment je vais je vais pas répondre
à la question comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour lutter contre ce discours de ce
discours de haine parce que ça nous
mènerait très très loin et qu'il y a
beaucoup de de politique qui peuvent
être concernées en fait par ça mais le
mot en fait elle m'a intéressé et on
réfléchissant
comme citoyen comme politiste à la
question de la démocratie la démocratie
libérale à sa mise en cause en fait par
par les populismes et les extrémismes de
plus en plus en fait je suis convaincu
que l'un des clivages en fait politique
les plus les plus importants c'est un
clivage en fait qui est de nature
émotionnelle
et on le voit en tout cas dans ce pays
on le voit dans d'autres pays européens
aussi
on voit que l'ensemble des crises pour
faire le lien avec notre sujet de ce
soir
je suis une quinzaine d'années nous
ferons entrer dans un dans ce que Pierre
Rosanvallon pour lequel j'ai aussi une
pensée évidemment aujourd'hui a appelé
un retour en fait de l'âge des
incertitudes et ce retour de l'âge des
incertitudes il produit de la peur de
l'angoisse de l'anxiété
évidemment en fonction des réponses qui
sont apportées ou qui ne sont pas
apportées à ce type d'angoisse ça génère
en fait des émotions politiques
particulières qui produisent des effets
politiques
la peur ne produit pas les mêmes effets
politiques que la colère le ressentiment
le sentiment de fierté blessé le
sentiment d'être méprisé le sentiment de
ne pas être reconnu tout ça génère
évidemment
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la
colère voire de la haine en fait si on y
répond pas et de ce point de vue là je
pense que les parlements pour répondre à
la question ou un rôle important à jouer
parce que les parlements sont composés
de gens qui sont élus
qui sont en contact de la population qui
sont les mieux placés pour prendre le
pouls de nos concitoyens et ça
permettrait évidemment de réduire
l'écart que l'on voit abyssal entre ce
ils ont un certain nombre de décisions
en tout cas de discours qui sont qui
sont tenus qui sont pris et la réalité
effectivement du ressenti des émotions
voire des passions qui nourrissent
aujourd'hui des divisions et des
clivages de plus en plus structurant et
je pense pour finir sur sur ce sujet sur
cet argument que
c'est majeur en fait ce défi qui est
lancé la démocratie libérale parce que
le libéralisme de manière générale à la
fois comme doctrine intellectuelle et
aussi politique a toujours eu beaucoup
de mal à penser en fait les émotions
c'est quelque chose qui a cherché en
fait en permanence historiquement et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à substituer les
intérêts en fait aux passions si on
laisse ce champ là complètement vacant
on sait que la nature politique comme la
nature a horreur du vide on sait très
bien que ce vide discursif en fait il
sera occupé par des forces radicales et
extrémistes
je voudrais quand même ajouter une
petite nuance à ce que vous avez deux
petites nuances premièrement sur la
question de l'incertitude la démocratie
par définition par essence c'est le
régime de la certitude on le savait très
bien quand les démocraties s'opposé au
régime totalitaire qui prônait la
transparence de la société elle-même et
au fond le régime de la certitude
absolue donc le problème ce n'est pas le
pour moi ce n'est pas le retour de
l'incertitude mais ce sont des
conditions aujourd'hui qui font que
l'incertitude ne peut pas être acceptée
ou elle comment dire elle ne peut pas
être assumée c'est-à-dire que
on a abandonné l'idée l'avenir dessiné à
l'avance pour se trouver confronté non
pas à l'acceptation de l'incertitude
mais l'angoisse devant la certitude donc
le problème c'est peut-être la manière
dont par exemple des institutions nous
permettraient d'appréhender la question
de l'incertitude c'est-à-dire
la question de du sens de l'orientation
d'une société ne demande pas qu'on est
un avenir qui est préfiguré à l'avance
si on a un avenir préfiguré à l'avance
c'est pas la peine d'agir donc c'est il
y a quelque chose qui est
la possibilité de l'action elle est
commandée par l'incertitude et la
deuxième chose que je deuxième petite
nuance je pense que ce n'est pas la
démocratie libérale en tant que telle
qui
comment dire ne n'arrive pas à penser la
question des des émotions ou des
sentiments je pense que c'est une un
certain type de rationalité économique
qui prétend se substituer à une
rationalité politique est une
rationalité élargie je rappellerai ici
Montesquieu
quand on dit quand même qu'il est l'un
des pères
du libéralisme politique Montesquieu
distingue à propos des régimes la nature
d'un régime et son principe la nature
d'un régime c'est son fonctionnement
c'est la façon dont ça marche
l'organisation les procédures les
institutions et le principe d'un régime
c'est ce qui le fait d'être et
Montesquieu dit qu'est-ce qu'il le fait
d'être ce sont les sentiments bon au 18e
on disait les sentiments donc l'amour de
la liberté ou par exemple la crainte
dans une tyrannie le sens de l'honneur
dans une monarchie etc donc peut-être
que c'est un travers beaucoup plus je
dirais récent que d'avoir oublié que il
y a une sensibilité politique qu'il faut
intégrer à l'intérieur de la rationalité
et par exemple
l'Aristote la colère est un sentiment
politique
la peur beaucoup moins
voilà
oui c'est vrai mais là mais de façon un
petit peu la peur et les transformer
elle est élaborée de manière rationnelle
mais quand les Grecs disaient par
exemple un homme qui est incapable de se
mettre en colère n'est pas un homme
libre
il voulait dire aussi que la colère
était partie prenante d'un certain type
de rationalité politique que
j'appellerai une rationalité élargie
donc je crois qu'effectivement c'est un
problème fondamental que d'arriver à
réintégrer ce registre des sentiments du
sensible à l'intérieur de la réflexion
politique alors que nous sommes
maintenant dans un type de raisonnement
qui ne cesse de les opposer d'un côté la
rationalité calcule lente de l'autre les
émotions comment dire on pense à Platon
et vos peuple qui est la grosse bête en
proie
assez passion et assez dérives donc je
pense que ça c'est un enjeu fondamental
aussi que d'arriver à réarticuler les
deux voilà
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup à tous les trois encore
une fois merci au public et encore une
fois merci avant ces propos conclusifs
au président du Sénat pour nous
accueillir ici
c'est pas l'exercice le plus simple
c'est à la fois synthèse et contractions
de texte une épreuve terrible dans les
concours
d'abord merci
donc trois intervenants merci à ceux qui
ont échangé et merci à mes collègues
d'avoir été présents parce que ils ont
le vécu concret de la démocratie tout
d'abord répondre à l'intervenance salle
la démocratie ça ne résulte pas d'une
représentation comptable de chaque
fragment de la société
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
améliorer la représentativité je vois
bien comment elle s'est améliorée au fil
de 30 années parce que moi j'ai
l'avantage d'avoir vu un certain nombre
d'évolution j'ai été élu ici vice
Benjamin le même jour que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il était le benjamin voyez
j'ai tourné différemment mais
je dois dire que j'ai vu évoluer la
représentation et la représentation
c'est une diversité plus grande des
origines cette maison qui était
présentée comme l'assemblée du siècle et
la châtaigne n'a plus aujourd'hui que 5%
de représentants issus du monde agricole
ou du secteur agroalimentaire et quand
vous regardez la comparaison avec les
emplois en France et l'activité ça
dépasse si éloigné que cela mais
j'insiste sur le fait que ça n'est pas
une représentation comptable de chaque
fragment de la société ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il ne faut pas travailler
sur l'amélioration de la
représentativité et des procédures de
choix nous nous sommes naturellement
issus d'un choix très particulier mais
qui existe dans d'autres pays 550
000 élus locaux
choisissent les sénateurs mais eux-mêmes
ont été choisis par les citoyens dans
une dimension de proximité qui est
aujourd'hui par rapport à la démocratie
des attentes nous voyons bien
qu'aujourd'hui la proximité et moins
questionnée que la distance par rapport
aux citoyens et c'est donc la véritable
sujet
second point
peut-être reprenant ce que vous avez dit
Madame revaudalogne la tension entre un
système de pouvoir et des mœurs
la démocratie c'est aussi une forme de
société
et je crois qu'il ne faut pas se dire
que ça n'est pas une forme de société je
crois que c'est tout à fait essentiel et
comment on incarne une forme de société
des mœurs dans un système de pouvoir
au coeur de la réflexion
institutionnelle j'évoquais le bail de 5
ans
ça n'est pas que formel tout ça
et puis je voudrais aussi répondre
peut-être indirectement parce que au
Parlement l'ignore sans doute il y a des
possibilités pour les citoyens
d'intervenir
ça s'appelle les plateformes ont mis en
place maintenant il y a 8 ans que
naturellement nous dialoguons avec
très directement les élus locaux mais il
était Jordy aujourd'hui aux citoyens je
vois la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales elle est actuellement
en train de réfléchir et de conduire
dans la diversité politique la réflexion
sur le sujet de la fin de vie au delà de
la convention citoyenne et pardonnez-moi
je considère que la convention citoyenne
c'est quelque chose d'important mais
doit dire que dans la démocratie
représentative et il y a aussi cet
élément sur ces sujets dont il faut
débattre et voir comment nous évoluons
dans les mains
il y a aussi deuxième point en vous
écoutant
Thierry Chopin et Klaus vélo une tension
entre les niveaux nationaux et européens
l'Union européenne je crois appris des
cris successives par rapport à 2008 vous
l'avez dit et je dois dire que après une
période de doute la période de la
pandémie et pardonnez-moi de la réponse
vaccinale par rapport à d'autres pays on
a déjà oublié au début nous a beaucoup
interrogé je me souviens de mes
interrogations publiques sur ce sujet
mais on a vu que dans un dialogue dans
un secteur qui pourtant n'est pas de
compétence européenne la santé alors que
pardonner moi qui suis vétérinaire la
compétence santé animale est une
compétence partagée dans le cadre de la
politique agricole commune on savait
mieux lutter contre la pestorcine
africaine en Europe que contre le covid
pardonnez-moi et nous avons montré cette
capacité d'adaptation de compréhension
je dois dire que un certain nombre de
commissaires ont joué un rôle je pense
aussi à Thierry Breton sur ce sujet par
rapport à la réalité de l'adaptation
mais
les difficultés persistent et nous avons
quand même une dilution des
responsabilités
il y a une tentation mais c'est tous les
pouvoirs exécutifs je vais vous dire
mais particulièrement
parfois chez nous une tentation et je
reviens au Conseil européen de la
Commission européenne de contourner le
Parlement européen vous savez les
exécutifs dans notre pays quel que soit
les gouvernements ont une petite
tendance à aimer contourner le Parlement
il y a aussi madame mairesse évoqué
l'exigence de la collégation qui est un
point important le fait que le Parlement
européen réalise ou réactualisent ces
accords politiques après les élections
et non
en amont des élections c'est peut-être
un problème démocratique
c'est une tradition que vous connaissez
plus en Allemagne ou ailleurs que la
tradition de la coalition après les
élections mais ne jamais débattre avant
une élection pardonnez-moi ça nous
renvoie des débats actuellement en cours
de notre pays je rappelle qu'une
coalition pour moi c'est un projet un
contrat une majorité alors il y a les
majorité d'assemblages
et puis il y a les majorités qui se
construisent au travers des urnes c'est
aussi un élément de réflexion pour les
futurs il est essentiel me semble-t-il
aussi que le débat européen ne soit pas
la panache des institutions européennes
ou des exécutifs nationaux je crois pas
à une harmonisation par le haut des
attributions des parlements au sein
d'Union Européenne chaque État membre a
aussi ses spécificités enfin je vais
terminer sur la question fédérale qui a
été posée tout à l'heure c'est
naturellement une tentation que que nous
entendons
la existé nous avons eu des débats sur
la tentation fédérale je crois que
l'histoire de nos pays l'histoire de
l'Europe rend extrêmement difficile
cette approche en tous les cas vu de
France mais pas que de France et je le
dis parce que il me semble que les
citoyens d'aujourd'hui le modèle des
États-Unis est un modèle différent et il
a aussi des états fédéraux avec des
pouvoirs importants et des pouvoirs
parfois tellement importants que sur les
questions de société vous voyez les
États fédérés prendre des décisions sur
les questions de société qui s'opposent
j'allais dire à la volonté de l'État
fédéral mais je voudrais simplement
terminer en disant
qu'il me semble important dans la
démocratie de faire aussi un éloge de la
proximité
je pense que la démocratie quand elle
s'éloigne quand elle se verticalise
quand elle n'accepte pas les contrôles
tout à l'heure on parlait des contrôles
nous avons encore beaucoup de chemin à
faire dans le contrôle mais ici cher
Jean-Baptiste blanc la tradition du
contrôle est une tradition qui a été
introduite à l'époque par Alain powerp
et qui n'a jamais plu aux exécutifs quel
qu'il soit mais c'est une tradition qui
me semble contribue à la démocratie à la
réponse de proximité tous les cas je
voulais remercier grand continent
ça nous fait du bien ça nous décaps pour
ne pas toujours d'accord sur tout mais
le prof d'un débat et je le dis aussi
pour les citoyens mais ne croyez pas que
le droit de pétition ça n'est rien ici
nous avons adopté une nouvelle politique
en matière notamment de l'accompagnement
des adultes handicapés à partir du droit
de pétition nous venons sur un certain
nombre de sujets de sociétés de les
aborder par le droit de pétition droit
de pétition c'est pas des lobbys qui
agissent je d'ailleurs on est peut-être
vu dans la presse cet après-midi prendre
une décision sur l'attitude des lobbies
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de Parlement en France prend la décision
de mettre au pilori des attitudes de
lobbyiste à l'intérieur d'un parlement
et je l'ai fait parce que je pense que
le Parlement doit aussi examiner tout ça
avec une part d'objectivité
d'indépendance vous êtes sans doute dans
la maison la plus indépendante j'ai
toujours une formule ici on dit jamais
oui par discipline et jamais non par
dogmatisme c'est la marque du Sénat ici
il est vrai que nous procédons pas et ça
nous renvoie un système que vous avez
abordé nous sommes dans un système
présidentiel et Cher Thierry Chopin il
est vrai que le contrôle par le
Parlement
de l'exécutif notamment dans ces
décisions européennes n'a rien à voir
avec ce qui existe par rapport à mes
collègues damnoy où on réveille le
président de la Commission européenne ça
lui ferait beaucoup de bien la nuit
d'ailleurs pour accepter ou non une
décision au niveau du Conseil européen
c'est un élément sans doute qui manque
chez nous mais quel héritage j'allais
dire du moment gaulliste la création
symbolisme qui vous dit ça de la
Cinquième République où le chef de
l'État a voulu sur des sujets de
politique international avoir les mains
plus libres et c'est l'héritage de la
Cinquième République en tous les cas
merci de nous aider quelque part nous à
nous décaper et je peux vous dire que la
démocratie notre président de la
commission des affaires sociales l'a
vécu en direct que ce soit avec les
partenaires sociaux ou ailleurs et que
c'est un moment qui permet d'ailleurs au
Parlement de se remettre en cause et
d'analyser un certain nombre de choses
en souhaitant que l'exécutif le fasse
aussi parfois merci à tous très bonne
soirée
[Applaudissements]